continental tire coaches corner Rick
Neuheisel set to join us as we recap
college football weekend your phone
calls coming up best in words to the
weekend he at the end of the Tennessee
Georgia game Clemson Louisville and
Michigan over Wisconsin we bring in Rick
Neuheisel CBS sports college football
analyst good morning Rick how are you DP
I'm doing well man long time no talk
everything good with you spectacular
absolutely spectacular where do you want
to start today well I think that that
that showdown in in Death Valley the
Clemson version of Death Valley anyway
was one for the ages those are two
sensational quarterbacks both teams go
for over five hundred yards of offense
that second quarter there were like five
or six drives that neither one had the
ball for more than a minute right back
and forth it a would not shock me that
Louisville could earn their way all the
way back and still make the Final Four
can you look and you were quarterbacks
coach in the NFL can you look at those
two guys and project at all of what they
would be like in the NFL start with
deshaun watson have you seen enough
where you go okay i understand what kind
of quarterback he'll be in the NFL you
know Deshawn is is such a talent and
he's more talented when the game's on
the line I think when he forgets about
trying to make plays and just does what
the situation calls for as we witnessed
in the national championship game I
think he really comes to life in 1985
Homer Smith was the offensive
coordinator at UCLA was my coach he told
me this with your Bo Jackson won the
Heisman Trophy he said some day boe/d
Jackson will play quarterback and that's
what we're seeing when Cam Newton you
know when the high-spin trophy in Auburn
and now deshaun Watson and Lamar Jackson
these guys are you know putting their
teams on their shoulders and can do it
with both their arm and legs that's what
we're seeing these great athletes taken
over at the quarterback position and
then ultimately when you project them at
the NFL level now staying in the pocket
are they going to be accurate enough to
do that and I think still
a ways away from doing that but
certainly gifted enough to say great
things can ensue what you hope is that
an NFL team in selecting these guys will
also you know incorporate some of the
things that make them special within the
offense but you have these quarterbacks
at a young age who were successful
watching dak Prescott Trevor Simeon even
Paxton Lynch came in and it Jimmy
Garoppolo what is it about not and I
also say it helps having a good team
around a young quarterback to help him
but what is it about these quarterbacks
I mean why's dak dak Prescott looking
like he's Troy Aikman well he has a lot
of what Russell Smith excuse me to
Russell Wilson has you know he has that
ability to make people miss in the
pocket not necessarily to create running
for him not you know quarterback design
runs but but basically that elusive
extend the playability and keep his eyes
downfield Dan Mullen at Mississippi
State transitioned their offense from
the offense that we stack Prescott
running the football almost a thousand
yard rusher his junior year into an
offense that was really all about him
throwing the ball and getting
understanding past concepts and getting
through reads of all the different
patterns structures and so he was ready
to play the next level and because the
ability to extend plays and create
offense it it's disruptive to a defense
and also in that offense starts to get
rhythm Russell Wilson had the same
impact on the Seattle Seahawk offense
and now you're seeing it with these
other guys he's Rick Neuheisel former
college coach now working for CBS Sports
joining a stand Patrick show explain to
me the ending of the Tennessee Georgia
game if somebody didn't see it how would
you sum it up and can I give credit to
good coaching or do I give more blame
too bad coaching well I think there's a
lot to be taught off again to that game
film okay first of all you know Jim
Chaney the coordinator for Georgia knows
better than to drop a freshman
quarterback back into your end zone and
take a sack fumble there to give
Tennessee the lead but the reason you
travel even if you're an ass
miss Georgia to the state of Washington
which I think might be in terms of
distance as far as you can go in the
continental United States is for a
strong armed guy like Jacob Eason they
were in covered too now if you recall
the baltimore ravens super bowl run Joe
Flacco had third and forever against the
Denver Broncos my old usually safety
Rahim Moore was in cover two and all
sudden cover two doesn't have enough for
when you're sending guys down the field
and the tight end had been the most
favorite targets of the safety bit on
the tight end and Nelson that guy just
ran all the way down the field and and
touchdown georgia ten seconds left we're
all scratching our heads how did this
happen the hobnail boot Larry Munson
somewhere up in the heavens talking
about they went haha and then 20 yards
of penalties yeah a guy taking his
helmet off which is ridiculous because
it was celebrity celebration type thing
but 15 yards there five yards for being
off sides in a and a clip that I don't
understand Tennessee was lined up as if
it was going to be a nun sidekick knew
what are you doing and they get the heck
of a return four seconds left on the
clock in a place where they can throw a
Hail Mary and Georgia puts a deep to
tallest guy Jenkins back there number
seven but he's seven yards deep then
somebody needs to tell him that the
touchdown tell us when he gets over that
goal line he doesn't need to be seven
yards deep and they don't even make a
play in this juwan Jennings the next big
thing at Tennessee who had the touchdown
against Florida the week before goes up
and snatches it before anybody can touch
it for Georgia so there's lots to teach
off Hail Mary defense but you talk about
just pure passion that that game was
wild and everything you could imagine
how many teams do you think would go
undefeated this year at day's end I
would say no more than two is Houston
one of those teams I would say they have
a great chance to be their loan
challenge actually they big I think
they've got two challenges certainly the
louisville game
Louisville comes to houston that
thursday in november and then the
memphis game following it because
there'll be some measure of a hangover
after that and and I think Memphis is is
a decent offense they hung 77 on Bowling
Green so that game will be a little
challenge I think they'll be ready for
that American Conference championship
game and but but I think there are two
hurdles there and then I think either
Ohio State or Alabama one of those two
will make it and Tom Herman's now the
object of desire here and you got a lot
of these programs and and and you know
this what happens with that athletic
director of the Boosters when you're
your school is struggling and you know
that you've got that knight in shining
armor who's out there who can all of a
sudden change your fortunes and Tom
Herman can only have one job so how does
this work if your LSU or USC or Texas
yeah you know I mean Texas you hit the
nail on the head right there and we
talked about this last week you know
when LSU made their job open everybody
circled the wagons around Tom Herman you
know it's going to be a distraction for
him the rest of the year but I said
before in an anticipation of the
oklahoma state texas game patience which
has never been long suit of those in the
burn orange it just got really really
small and to have another big number
hung on that defense which is supposed
to be Charlie's you know a baby on the
defensive side of the ball I'm promising
you it is torched that seat that he's
sitting on because Tom Herman coached at
Texas those guys who are dying to be
relevant with those private planes that
say hokum then keeps driving flying into
austin texas are going are we going to
let LSU take this guy from us and who
are we going to make a play I think USC
will settle down I think Sam Donald
their quarterback is going to prove to
be a really good player they just waxed
Arizona State over the weekend but that
Texas and LSU fight over tom herman is
is real great to talk to you and the
dance got to meet your son at rams camp
it was the highlight of his little
internship with the Rams you know it
wasn't jared goff it wasn't Todd Gurley
it was the danna that's who he said were
the coolest of all the cool and what
made the entire summer worth it yes
Polly Dan the young neuheisel was
basically running the camp he was all
over the Hard Knocks cameras he was he
was omnipresent finding away for some
camera time mugging the camera go figure
yeah you taught him well thank you Rick
boys always good to be with you have a
great week that's Rick Neuheisel
remember when Rick would play songs we
got the guitar and then all of a sudden
CBS hires him and then they go could you
do some of those songs you do on the Dan
Patrick show so then I said all right we
can't have Rick do any of the songs with
the guitar and he was awesome with that
hope you're happy CBS for any surface
and every season there's a continental
tire that delivers superior performance
unparalleled safety it's your vehicle
and upgrade with Continentals maximum
performance tires for more information
continental tire calm from speedway to
driveway continental puts you in the
driver's seat Continental Tire coaches
corner the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience